では　よろしくお願いします
今日は集中力について話してみます
自由にならない集中力の不思議ということで
幸福のための精神統一
鍛錬法
集中力はまあ良いことですと
後ろ見えますかね
大体宗教と関係なく 集中力でいえば
宗教に興味ない人々でもね
大変いいことだとは言ってますね
英語でいうとconcentration
concentrationは決して悪いことじゃないということは
世間一般的にみんな知ってるんです
集中力は良いものだという考えが固定してますね
人間の経験から成り立っている考えなので
違うとは言えないんですね
例えば心理学の研究者たちやらね
集中力はいいものだと言っているのは
いろいろ調べて研究しておっしゃってるでしょうに
学問の場合でも スポーツの場合でも 研究の場合でも
どんなところでもやっぱり集中力っていうものは
とても必要だとは思っているし
それなりのデータがあって言っていると思います
確かに仕事 勉強 訓練などで集中力があれば
効率は高いし 能力も向上するんです
そういう証拠もありますね
しかし問題はこの必要不可欠な
集中力は自由にならないことです
そんなに大事なことだったら
みんなあればいいでしょうに
能力は向上するわ 効率は上がるわ
すぐ何でもできるようになるんだというね
大変いいことなのに
勉強する時でも集中力があれば勉強はうまくいくわ
勉強したものはもう覚えてしまうというね
いいことばっかりなんですが
そんなにいいことならね
スポーツをする時でも
やっぱり集中力が必要なんですよ
集中力があればうまく行くので
いくらプロであっても集中力がなくなっちゃうと
もうダメになるのです
なのに これはなかなか自由にはならないのですね
良いものなんですけど なかなか手に入らない
と言うことも また事実なんです
では なぜ自由にならないのかについて考えておきましょう
集中力は良いものだと信じているだけで
集中力があれば 物事はスムーズに進むことも知っているだけで
集中力とは心理的にどのようなものか
育てられるものか
先天的なものかなどは
調べたことはないんです
心理学の本とか読んでみてください
いかに集中力を育てるのかという本は全然ないのです
あらゆる研究していますよ
この病気はどうなったんですか？あの病気はどうなったんですか？
この現象 この病名を研究しましょうというのはあるが
いかに集中力というものを育てるのか
集中力って心理学的にどんな現象なのかと
全然研究していないんです
面白いんですよ
こんなに必要なものはなぜ研究しないんですかね
例えば 対人恐怖症とか 競争恐怖症とかね
そういう心理的なものを分析するんですけど
だから それよりも普通の人間がより立派な人間になれるように
心理学の世界で研究する方々はね
集中力について研究して
もっと現代的な 機械などいろいろなものを使えますから
我々はそんなのもにアクセスもできませんし
脳波を測ってみるわ
モニター画面に出したりとか あらゆることをやっているのに
集中力って何なのかとなかなか誰も研究しないんですね
面白いんですね そんなに大事なことなのに
内容を理解できれば集中力は育てます
だから残念ですけど
これから仏教の世界の話から話さないといけないんですね
集中力ってどういうものかと言う内容を理解しておけば
（集中力は）育てられます
育てることができれば自由になります
自分の手に入れます 自分のものになります
集中力について詳細に学ぶということで
これから学んでみましょう
集中力とは 心に入った対象から
離れることなく対象についていることです
集中力っていうのは心に入ったものから離れないんですね
それと一緒にべったりとついてるんです
その状態なのです
反対に 心は好き勝手に様々な対象に
情報に振り回されることは
集中力がないということなんです
例えば 本を読む例で考えてみると
本は読んでいるんですけど
いろんな耳に入る音が気になったり
人が隣で喋っていることを聞いてしまったり
それについて考えたりしたり
また本も読んでいると集中力って全くないんですね
集中力というのは 自分が本を読んでいて
隣で誰か二人が喋ってるんですけど
何喋ってるかさっぱりわからなかったというならば
あんた聞いてるの？ いや全然聞いてないんだよと
あんた何を言ったのかと
後で言うぐらいだったら もう集中力があって
本を読んだことになるんですね
集中力の定義はまず理解しておきましょう
自分のやることから 自分の心の対象ですね
しっかりとした定義は
この対象についているんですね
釘付けているんですね
離れないんです
それが集中力なんですね
風に揺れる旗のように心に安定感がないならば
集中力がないんですね
この旗の例は仏典にも出ているものだからね
集中力がないことを仏教では掉挙（じょうこ）と言います
心は興奮 混乱している状態
揺れるんですね
激しく心が揺れているならば 集中力は全くないんだと
だから揺れる心では何もできません
揺れ動く心で本を読んでも
読んだり 別のことを考えたり
全く関係ないことに心が行ったり また読んだり
また人が言うことを気になったり
それに答えたりしたり
頭なんか戦争状態なんですね
それでは頭は成長することもないし
読んだ内容も理解できないし 覚えることもないですね
集中力がないこというのはすごく心が弱いです
集中力がある時 心は基層に建てられた柱のようです
しっかりした基層に建てられた柱というものは
揺れると困るでしょう
家なんか作る場合はね 柱だけでもしっかりと
頑丈で揺れ動かないでほしいんですね
ですから　しっかりと対象について
揺れない 動かない状態が集中力なんですね
それぐらい定義がわかれば
もう簡単に集中力を育てられると思いますよ
それから集中力について分析してみます
先天的にある集中力
聞いたことがないでしょう
脳細胞が発達していない生命体は
遺伝的にプログラムされていないものを知ることさえもしないんです
ちょっとややこしい文章ですけど
動物は自分に関係ないものはもう知り得ないんです
アヒルとか生まれてすぐ動くものを見たら
それ親だと思うし
実際自分の親は見ても もうわからないんですね
最初に目に入ったものは親ですから
例えば猫なんかは ものが動いたらすぐ興味をもつのです
動かないものは猫に見えているかどうかさっぱりわからないんですね
それでよく猫を観察してみると
藪に入ったりしていろんな動く鳥とかね
狙っているんですね
その時すごい集中力なんです
その狙っているものをじっと見て
目がどこにも行かないんです
それで体しっかり変わるんですよ
獲物を狙っていると体しっかり変わって
動き方やら 尾っぽの振り方が全部一つに
徹底的に集中するんです
その時に限って 私は時々猫に喋るんですね
聞こえないんです
もうかなりの集中力
それでもいろいろ喋ったりなんとかすると
集中力切れちゃうでしょ すぐ忘れてるんで
すぐ忘れるので 今は獲物を狙っていたんだけど
それができなくなったということがもう忘れているんです
集中力が切れたったんです
今まで何やっていたのかとか
動物殺すんじゃないよとか
私は説教するんですけど
猫は何のことかと
そんなことやったのかっていう顔をするんですね
動物たちは何かやる場合はね
しっかり集中力でやっているんです
それは先天的なんですね
他のことを理解させようと思っても無理です
ミミズはミミズの世界で生きているのであって
アリはアリの世界でね
例えば食べ物があったら
どこであっても アリたちがサーとそちらへ行くでしょう
それで殺虫剤かけられて死ぬかもしれない
（しかし）そんなことを考える余裕がないんです
あのカラスみたいに周りも見て
パッと取って逃げようというような思考はないんです
食べ物があったらそちらに行く
ネズミになってくると違いますね
食べ物があったら狙いたいんですけど
周りをよく見て人間いるのかどうかね
見て餌のところに行くんですね
それぞれ動物たちにはそういう集中力があったりなかったりです
餌をまいてアリを捕まりたければ　いとも簡単です
ネズミは捕まりませんね
アリは迷子にならない
ミツバチは花が咲いているところに飛んで
自分の巣にちゃんと帰ります
私たちはミツバチの巣がどこにあるのか
探すのがすごく難しいです
同じ木たくさんありますね？野生の場合は
あるいは養殖している場合でも 同じでしょう？
形も同じで 看板書いてないし 番号振ってないし
あなた方ミツバチたちはB3だよとかね
あなた方はB5だよ とかないんですよ
ただたくさん箱を並べて飼っているだけ
それぞれちゃんと自分の箱に行くんです
迷子になることはないんです
アリとか 皆様はあまり目に入りませんが
私はかなり野生の動物を見るのは好きですけどね
私は人間見ると気持ち悪くなるんだからね
アリを見ていると全然そんなことはないんです
結構距離は行くんですよ
よくも迷子にならないんですね
それで私がわざと迷子にさせるんです
見ていると （アリは）並んでいくんだからね
匂いとかを嗅いで道を作ってますからね
私はアリが歩いている道の間で指で削ったりして
拭いたりすると
その間の匂いがなくなるんですね
そこでカチッと止めて待ってるんですね
動かなくなっちゃって
それで群がっちゃうんで
そこでやっぱり勇気のある一匹ぐらいは
なんとなく
どこでもいいからと先に進んだんですね
その一匹が進んだら
そこからまたアリたちがついて行くんですね
ちゃんと自分が決めた目的に行く
決めたことから脱線しない 揺れ動きはない
それが集中力だと定義しましたから
なんかアリにもあるんですね 見てみれば
人間の中でも頭がそれほど優れていない人々は
決まったパターンで生きている
知識的にあまり優れていない方々についてはね
皆様経験があると思いますけど
いくつか（のパターン）はできます
それはしっかりするんです
私たちならもう面白くないとか飽きちゃいますけど
そういう方々は自分に決まった仕事をしっかりしてくれるんです
知識的にトラブルある方々にとってもちゃんと仕事はあるんですよ
何かを組み立てるとかね
何かを教えてあげれば 例えば箱にシールを貼るとかね
教えてあげれば それはしっかりと 何のこともなくやっているんです
しかし 箱の中身も調べて
売り物になるかならないかと品質も管理してから
OKシール貼ってくださいと言っちゃうと
これはできないんです
だから誰かが品物を調べて
品質はOKだったら 流してあげれば
その人はそちらに OK シール出して
別のベルトで来るものには ×シールを貼ってくれたりはします
だから結構 可愛いといえば可愛いんですよ
もうよくわかりやすいし
こういうことを言ったらこの人怒るだろうとかね
こういうことを知っちゃうと混乱するだろうとか
それははっきりしていて管理もしやすいし
その集中力があるところでうまく利用すれば
本人にも収入があって
我々普通の社会にも負担ではないんですね
余計なことを考えられない だから考えてないんです
だからその対象にしっかりしているんです
これも集中力ですよ
別なことに誘惑することは難しい そういう人々は
例えばワンパターンの仕事をずっとしていて
誰か横から話しかけて 何かやりましょうと言っても
わからないんです
出てこないんです 誘惑することは難しいんです
そういうことで 先天的な集中力なんですね
先天的な集中力は単純に生命を維持するための基本的な力です
誰にでもあるんです ない人はいないんです
ない生命はいないんです この先天的な集中力は
それはどういうことかって やっぱりあの
猫が動くものにしっかりと集中しないと
どうやって獲物を取るんですかね
だから生きていられなくなるんです
人間にも先天的ないろいろ集中力はついています
なぜ先天的についているのかというと
生きるために必要なんです
生き続くために 死を避けるために
でないと みんな早くも死んでしまいます
だから 人間でものすごく混乱している
頭がどうにもならない興奮状態でいる
イカれてる人でも道路を歩くと気をつけてるでしょう
それでもあんまりにも興奮して
右も左もわからなくなっちゃうと
車にぶつかったりもする
しかし それはあまりにもひどい状態で
普通なら車にはぶつからないんです
それぐらいの集中力は人間にはあるんです
ということで
どんな生命にも先天的にある程度で集中力があります
これでやっと死なないで生きているんです
あるパターンから離れることはできないという集中力なので
能力としてとして見れるが
無能として見ることもできるんです
文章がややこしいんですから 簡単に言います
集中力というのはありがたいことであると最初に言ったでしょう
あれはすごいという場合は能力なんですね
宝物なんですね
しかし 先天的な集中力考えてみると
あれは能力か能力でないか どちらにしますかと
例えば 認知的な問題ある方々も
それなりの施設などで仕事をしていますよ
しかし 大胆な仕事はできないんですね
大胆な仕事はできないんですね
認知過程でちょっとトラブルがある方々は
それって能力というべきか
能力がないというべきかというね
見方によって変わってしまいます
時々我々平気でね
あの人にはそんなすごいことをできないんだから
こういう仕事を頼みましょうと
いうことになるんですね
しかし それも本当は先天的な集中力には変わりはありません
そこで 皆様はこの先天的な集中力っていうことはね
例えばもう日本で長く生きて人生経験あるでしょう
じゃあ突然外国に行ったらどうします？
何もできなくなるんです
じゃ フランスにでも行ってレストランに行って
じゃあ注文してみてください
何か食べ物でも
混乱しちゃって訳がわからなくなっちゃってね
フランス料理の名前を聞いたことがありますけど
カタカナで書いてないんだから 毒だと思っちゃうし
だってフランスの文字っていうのは
書いてるものじゃないんだから 読む場合は
我々普通のローマ字は読めますけど
フランス語は書かれた通りではない
発音は別の発音をするんです
ドイツ語の食べ物の名前を聞いただけで
発音はできますけどね
食べ物じゃない感じしますよ
なんかすごい厳しい単語ですからね
これって食べ物でしょうかと
だからもう私たち慣れてないんですね
でも皆様には焼肉とかね
しゃぶしゃぶとかね
言うともういとも簡単に
食べる前にもう美味しく味を感じているんです
そういうことで
私たちには先天的な集中力があって
場所が変わると
ちょっと対応できなくなってしまいますね
その時は失ってしまいますね 先天的な集中力は
動物園なんかは 最近あまり動物がいないんだからね
贅沢に（環境再現を）やってますけど
動物園の檻の中にいる虎やライオンはね
大変厳しいんですよ
自分の環境の中でいると落ち着いてちゃんと仕事できるんです
だからなんとなくそういう自然環境を作ろうとね
動物園は頑張ってますけど
あまり意味がないと思いますよ
それだったらもう獲物を生きたままで出さないと
虎が狙って 取って食べるようにとかね
とにかくぶつ切りした肉をそのまま入れていますから
やっぱり不自然は不自然なんですね
虎にとっては
上野動物園の猿のために
山みたいなものを作って コンクリートでね
見る限り不自然で
猿たちはものすごいストレス溜まってると思います
そんなもんじゃないんだからね 森の中っていうのは
森の中で落ち着いていて 集中力あるんだから
本当に自分の生きている力を発揮するんですよ
鳥たちも力いっぱい歌ったりするし
動物たちも力いっぱい鳴いたり叫んだり
いろいろ楽しく生活しているんです
自分の命を支えてくれる環境で
集中力っていうのは出てきます
社会に出たら無口な人でも
家ではよく喋りますからね
また社会に入ったらまた何も喋れなく
なっちゃうんですね 環境が変わって
そういうことだから それ能力ですかね？
あるいは能力がないということですかね
家でペラペラ喋る 喧嘩する 理屈つけてくるわとかね
そういう人は社会に入って 学校で
どこか行ったところで黙っているならば
これが能力か能力でないか どちらにするかって
一応能力がないっていうことにしなくちゃいけないんですね
しかし私が言いたいのは
それも先天的な集中力ですよと
問題は環境からずれると機能しないんですね
私たちは陸の上ではかなり体力があって
走ったり何でもできそうでしょうし
体力はあることは確かにありますけど
水に入ってみたらもう魚に負けますね
小さな魚でも攻撃してくると どうすることもできなくなっちゃうんです
大変危険なんです
体力でもその環境が変わると機能しない
サメが偉そうなことをするんだけど
人間を脅したり 何でも食べたり
サメを陸の上に上げてみれば何もできません
いくら鋭い歯があってもね
もう噛もうともしないんです
ただ自分が暴れるだけで
でも水の中でどうなるのかというと大変危険なんですね
だからそれは体力 集中力じゃないんです
体力は生き延びるためにあります
しかしそれはどんな環境で使うのかということも先天的に決まっている
集中力もその環境で機能するんですね
環境から離れたらもう
働かないというものになっているんです
人間の場合はマインドコントロール、暗示をかけるなどに
使用される
我々の先天的な集中力を
世界でかなり悪用されています
そこは誰でも人間だから知ってます
人間が何に夢中になるのか
例えば人間というのは
言葉にすごく酔うんです
本当に危ないんです
言葉に酔うんだから
意味がどうでもいいんです
理屈はまるで崩れても 気にもしない
すごい迫力があって かなり耳触りが良い言葉で
喋り出すとみんなもう圧倒されちゃって
暗示かけられちゃってマインドコントロールされるんです
私は時々そういう宗教組織に行ってみたんですけど
キリスト教関係の新興宗教組織たくさんありますから
なんか舞台で泣き叫ぶは
神様よ！父親よ！
この人を助けてくださいと
ほら！見て！神様はあなたのことを見てる！
ものすごく力強く言う
みんな感動して バカどもたちが涙ポロポロで
単なるあのバカにマインドコントロールされているだけなんですけど
皆様は自分の体で神の存在を感じているではないですか？
いきなり そう感じてるでしょう？と言ったら
いいえ、違いますよと言える？言えないんですよ
なんて情けない人間かと
ちょっとでもうなずいたら すぐ舞台に上げさせられて
この方に神の恵みは今降りかかっているんだぞとかね
これからは大変幸福なものだよとかね
あれやこれやと言って人を馬鹿にするんです
だから特に仏教を宗教だとしたくないんですから
宗教はみんなそうやってマインドコントロール
暗示をかけて
人間は人間でなくなるようにするんですね
それが我々のこの先天的な能力を悪用しているんです
だから犬にもできますからね 色々なことを教えると
そこは慣れてしまいますね
カラスでも飼ってみてください 何のことなく人間と同じく生活し始まるんです
喋ったりもするんです
いろいろ鳥飼うんだけど
カラスの方が一番可愛いと思いますよ
すごく頭が良くて
よく喋ったりして
そこで他の鳥たちは同じことを繰り返すんですけど
カラスも同じなんですけど
なんとなく反応するんです 対話するんです
わかっているかどうか分かりませんけど
よく対話までするのです
楽しいです それになってくると
決して病気にならないんだから飼いやすいんです
カラスを飼いなさいという話じゃないんだから
カラスでも鳥でも飼ってあげて
毎日同じことを言うと そこを慣れて
ちゃんとその人を見るとその言葉をかけるとかね
あるお寺で住職さんがインコとかという鳥を飼っていたんです
住職さんがいつもその鳥と遊んでいるんですね 喋ったりして
若い弟子も二人いて
この長老は弟子たちにもなんとかこのいろいろ愛称を作ったりして
からかっているんですね
長老は自分の弟子のことはもうすごい好きで
いろいろからかったり使ったりするんで
言ってる言葉が 若者は嫌なんですね
長老に言われると何も言えませんけど
他の人が言うとすごい失礼になるんです
この長老は何をやってるのかというと
あの二人がいない時に
（鳥に）自分が言っていること からかうために使ってる単語を
教えてあげたりして
それでこの鳥もちゃんと呼んでくる時
すごい失礼な言葉で
なんか（弟子を）馬鹿にしているんですね
それで弟子たちはあまりいい気分じゃないでしょうね
もう鳥にも馬鹿にされると
（弟子の）その顔を見て 長老が一人で勝手に喜んでいるのです
オウムにしても ちゃんと区別して
この人が来るとこの言葉 あの人が来るとあの言葉と
マインドコントロールされているんですね
そういうのは集中力がないとできないんです
暗示っていうのはすごい強引なことでしょ
暗示かける時でも先天的な集中力が必要になるんです
だから結構暗示にかけられてしまう人々の方が多いんです
他人に自分の心を管理できる状態になるので
明らかに危険です
先天的な集中力と言ってもありがたがったらちょっと危ないんです
気をつけた方がいいんです その先天的な集中力はみんなにあるんだから
どこでマインドコントロールされてしまうか
誰に暗示かけられてしまうか
誰に管理されてしまうか わかったものじゃないです
よくよく調べてください
自分の人生はあらゆるところで管理されていて
マインドコントロールされていて
いろいろ暗示かけられちゃって生きてるんですよ
大変です
ないという人はただ気づいていないだけ
だからちゃんと勉強した方がいいです
この先天的な集中力は何なのか
それは生きるためには必要ですが
悪用されないように 自分が誰かの奴隷にならないように
どうすればよろしいかということは
これから学ばなくちゃいけないんです
人間は喋ることは理解しますよ
そういう集中力はあります
それでどうなるのかと
口が達者な人に会うともう大変ですよ
大きな事件で言うと いろいろ詐欺事件にね
やられちゃうでしょうに
なんかの組織があって
3ヶ月間で5,000万儲かるぞ とか言って
それでしゃべるは ビデオを作って放送したりして
すごい大胆な言葉で
この会社の社長がしゃべると みんな来る
おばあさん おじいさんたちが
自分の持ってるお金を全部出したりするんですね
それで 3ヶ月間で3,000万円儲かるところが
3ヶ月間経つと 会社の場所は別なところに
（会社の住所は）他の人が借りてるんですね
調べに行ったら別の会社になっていてと
もう遅いんですよ それから警察に訴えても
自分のなくなったお金が返ってこないんです
人間っていうのは金儲けをしようと思うと
すぐ集中力が生まれてくるんです
それ使ってるんです
最近痩せるということでね
これなら痩せますよと言った途端
それには集中力があるんです
痩せるためには何食べればいいかというね
屁理屈です 痩せたければ（何も）食べない方がいいでしょうに
飢えた方が痩せますけど
それで屁理屈で痩せるために
何を食べればいいかと考えるんです
それでダイエット食品の方が今 50%以上なんです
その中でも皆様が何買うのかというと
内容（中身）ではなくて
暗示が誰が上手にかけるのかっていうことなんです
マインドコントロールは誰がどういうふうにするのかと
特にテレビショッピングでは明確にわかりますね
派手に喋って 顔を知られていて
有名な人々を何人か
しかし売れてないというね
日本国民みんな知ってるんですけどあまり売れない
人々がそちらに集めて 驚くわ 演じるわ
でもすごく下手な演技でね だから売れないでしょうね
しっかり演技できればね 映画にも雇われますしね
それからそれなりにお金払って
視聴者も何人かを集めて
みんなにちゃんとお金を払うから
合図を出すときは笑う 合図を出すときは拍手する
合図出すときは歓声を上げたりするというね
全部（台本を）一応用意しているんです
フロアマネージャーという人がちゃんと
それをカンペに出すんです
これで品物を見せたら
「これはいいんだけど値段ですね…」と
また言うんですね
「やっぱり高いでしょう？」とかね
そう言ったら 商売やってる人は
「まあ そうなんですけど じゃあ今回に限って」
「２万円を切る」のだと
「1万950円にします」と
「あら！２万円を切ってる？」とものすごく驚いてくれます
周りの2人は
そこで見ている私はね
これはどこに買いに行っても
3,000円だったら手ごろな値段だよと
それでも俺にはいらんんだけど
どうしても必要な人は3,000円ぐらい払ってもいいやと
私はそこで逆を考えているんです
次にみんな驚いて それならもう友達にも紹介しなくちゃ
あれやこれやと大騒ぎ終わったところで
今回はそこで 2つ付けてあげますとかね
2つ付いたところでまたどこまでびっくりするのか
もうできないところまで
2つではなくて 一応もう1つまあいいや
ということで3つ出すんです
それで私は1個で十分なのに 3個はいりませんと
3個で1万950円で買っても値段が高すぎると
自分がもう（暗示が）かかってないんです
しかし かかるでしょう？ あんなダサい演技で
お金をかけているでしょう？テレビコマーシャルにしても
テレビショッピングにしても
別に通販で買うのは構いませんよ
買う場合はマインドコントロールされないで
自分の判断で
この品物なら私に必要だよと
これなら手ごろな値段だよと
あなた言ったんではなくて
自分の意思で買うんだぞという気持ちで買わなくちゃいけないんですよ
しかし 買わされるでしょ？
見事にマインドコントロールされているんですよ
そこで私たちはそういう巧みな言葉に酔ってしまう
もう他見えなくなるんですよ
これは先天的な集中力なんです
もし自分が好きな 自分がよく見慣れているタレントさんだったら
もうコマーシャルのところじゃなくて
こういう人々に興味が行ったりするんですね
そういう人々の仕草や喋りやら
それが面白くて見ているんです
普段は喜ばせる人間でしょうに
それでついつい買わされているということになっちゃうんですね
我々はものすごくカモにされているというか
悪用されているんです この世の中で
私はあらゆるコマーシャルを厳しく見て分析するんです
それぞれの国の国民性がコマーシャルに表れるんです
コマーシャルはなんで国民性が表れるんですかね
あれはマインドコントロールだからなんです
その国の国民の気持ちに合わせないと買わないというね
例えば日本のコマーシャルでは買いなさいということを言わないんですね
すごいことだ！もう今世紀の大発明だ！とかね
日本だけ世界で初めて開発したんだとかね
全部嘘ですけど
調べてみるとかなり前からイギリスやアメリカにあったものですけど
そういう風に言うだけで
通販でしか手に入りません 店では全然買えないとか言うんです
そう言われると買う気になるでしょ
日本人はそう言われると買う気になるんです
アメリカだったら今注文しなかったらあなたは損しますよと言うんですね
今注文しなかったらあなたはアウトだよと
だから買いなさいと言うんです
向こうは競争社会で
もう先に取った人は勝ちということだから
それで比較する他の品物があったら馬鹿にするんですね
日本ではそれはしません
日本の方々は日本のコマーシャルが一番かっこいいと思っている
インドコマーシャルは気持ち悪いと（私は）思ってますけど
インド人はあれがかっこいいと思っているんです
私にとっては世界中のコマーシャルは何でも気持ち悪いんです
だからじーとそういうものを見るんです
見て気持ち悪くなったりして分析してみたりはします
そういうことで 私たちは先天的に持っている集中力は
それぞれ人間みんな平等じゃないんだから
国によってそれぞれ違うし
年齢によってもその先天的集中力は変わるし
男性女性によっても変わってしまうしね
それに合わせて我々はかなり悪用されていると言うことがあります
オレオレ詐欺事件というのはね
日本以外できませんからね
いかに自分だけの世界に閉じ込められているのか
自分の孫の声がわからないというのはおかしいんです
普通は口先で何を言っても 家族ならもう気持ちわかるんですね
気持ちが通じるんですよ 例えば
子供は大丈夫ですよ 何の問題もないんだよと
お母さんに電話しても お母さんすぐわかる
なんか大変みたいとかね
なんか大変みたいな すぐわかるんです
だから私も時々誰かに電話して
随分時間が経って久しぶりに電話すると
どうですか？元気ですか？
あのね、あんた何かやっちゃったでしょう？
突然何のことなく聞くんです
何かやっちゃったでしょうねとか
知っているんです 波動で何かトラブルがあって
頭が混乱しちゃって 何とかしてほしいってことだからね
そこは読み取らないと ただの挨拶で終わっちゃうんです
そうですか？今何やってるんですか？
あれやこれやとか面白くないんですよ
それでは役にも立たないし
はっきり言いなさいよと あんた何やったのかと
そう言われるとバレたのかという感じで
もう何のことなく言うし
それにこちらアドバイスして
それで気分良く終わるし
うまくいったらもう電話かけてこない 半年とかね
いうことなんで だから
それも先天的な集中力で私もやってますけど
自分だけの世界に閉じ込められて
孫の面倒を見るべきだとか 孫を心配する
とにかく何かやってあげなくちゃという妄想だけがあって
どんな男が電話しても うまく騙されるんです
ちょっと聞いてみれば屁理屈だとすぐわかるでしょうに
今お金を銀行に入れなきゃ大変 ありえないでしょうに
孫やら息子やら　だいたい家族は知ってるんだから
言い方があるはずなんです その家族独特の
親と子以外あまりにも知らない いろいろ仕草やらね
音（声）とかね あるんです
コマーシャルの世界で生きているんだから
そちらにマインドコントロールされちゃって
他の先天的な能力が機能しなくなっているんです
先天的集中力は悪くないんだけど それをちゃんと生かしてほしいし
それを生かせば我々幸福で生きていられるし
この弱みがあるんだから そこは弄られて
いろんな危険なことになるんです
人は自分のために他人を支配管理しようとするんですね
人に管理されていいわけじゃないんです
人は自分のために相手を管理しようとしてるんです
宗教の場合も同じなんです
とにかく管理しようとしてるんですね 信者さんを
ものすごく独裁的なんですね 宗教の世界は
上はもう絶対的上で
神は絶対的神で
こんにちはとは言うんじゃないんですね
何か宗教組織に入ったら自分がいつでも身分が低くて
そうでなくちゃいけないんですね
どういうことを管理するのかというと日本の場合は
時々我は神様だと言っている人が
もうくたびれて死ぬでしょう
死ぬ時に今までふざけて贅沢三昧で生きていた
息子か娘が 改装(世襲)というか 次の(トップ)になることが
何よこれ？と 宗教は的精神的な世界だったら
最初の詐欺師が死んだら
次にそれなりの訓練をした詐欺師が行くことでしょうね
麻原(オウム真理教)の組織の場合でも娘か誰かが
次の最終解脱者になるようにもう設定してあったんです
日本の新興宗教みんなそうでしょう？
次は子供に行くんですね
例えば政治と言いながら 北朝鮮で
父が死んだら息子が永久的絶対的権力握っている
何様でしたっけ？将軍様ですね
学校の子供たちも毎朝毎晩拝まなくちゃいけない
どんな政治ですかね それで厳密
それで厳密に管理しているでしょう
マインドコントロール 厳密に思考の自由も動きの自由も何でもなくして
それで気分がいいと思いますかね
我々には弱みが当然あるんですよ 結局は先天的に
だから気をつけなくちゃいけないんですね
完全たる慈しみで
見返りは断然断る人はいるのでしょうか 世の中で
なぜ神を賛嘆しなくちゃいけないのかというと
脅されてるんですね
でなきゃ永遠な地獄に落ちるんだよと
逆になんで神がそんなにも褒めてほしいのかと
おかしいでしょうに
全知全能なのに人間どもに褒められなきゃいけない
どういうことですかね だからこの
誰か詐欺師たちが自分の収入を得るために
人々を馬鹿にして独裁気分になるために作る話ですよ
弱い人間がすぐ乗るんです
もし完全たる慈しみの人
人のことはもう完全に慈しむ
見返りなんか微塵も期待しない もう断る
それぐらいの人が管理しても構いませんよ
何も自分が損を受けません
自分がダメになるとすぐ助けてくれるんです
その程度の例えば微妙にこの母と子の関係ではあるんですね
どんな人間でも
やっぱり母が何か言うと変になってしまうんですね
断れようとも断ることもできないし
すごい複雑な状況になるんです
すごい凶暴な人でも
喧嘩しに行く 人を殺しに行くってみんな怖くて
ボロボロとしてるお母さんが名前（を呼んで）
お前こっちおいでと言ったら
素直に来るんです
いい加減にしなさいというと
ああしょうがない ということになるんですね
それもコントロールされてますよ 母という存在に
それが決して悪くはないんです
母にマインドコントロールされていることは
なぜならば 母は自分の子供には
不幸になってほしいとは思わないんですね
全然思わないし 思えないし
母と父以外はね 気をつけた方がいいんです
しかし我々の母父というのは完全じゃないんでしょうね
それは人々にも自分の欲やらいろいろあるでしょうね
自分の見方というものもあるし 一つも完全じゃないんです
危ないのは危ないんだけど
でもやっぱり自分のことを心配しているんだから
まあそんなに悪いことにはならなかった 今までは
正覚者である釈尊さえ人をマインドコントロール
管理しようとしなかったんです
仏教の場合 お釈迦様というのは完全たる人格者で
完全たる慈しみがあって
悟りに達しているんだから
何一つもいらないんです
もう人生はもう完了しているんです
輪廻脱出しているんです
何もいらん
しかし人のことは心配する
それだけ
心配して 人々は修行したから（と言って）
お釈迦様には何の得もないんです
余計な迷惑やと思いつつ説法していたんです
できればやめたいんだと ややこしいんだと
そこまでのお釈迦様なのに
人を管理しようと一回もやってないんです
逆のことを言うんです
はっきりと私は教えるだけだよと
これがもう世界一上手だよと 教えるのは
しかし頑張るのは君たちであると
自分の力で幸福になりなさいよと
やり方は教えてあげる
それで話は終わりだと
それでいかにこの人を管理するために
仏教が現れてないということは
あるエピソードを作ってあるんです
お釈迦様が見た夢だと悟る前に
これはおそらく作り話かもしれません
あるいはお釈迦様が実際そういう夢を見たかもしれません
すごい糞尿の山（不浄の山）があって
釈尊がその糞尿の山を歩いているんですね
糞尿の汚い山だから
気持ちいいわけじゃないでしょ
もう触れたくもないんだけど
どうしようもない 夢の中だからね
糞尿の上を歩かなくちゃいけない
その夢の解説は
釈尊がブッダになって悟ってからは
世間はあらゆるものを寄付する お布施をするんだと
人々のお布施で溢れてしまいますよ
しかしブッダにとってはそれらは糞尿だと
よかったよかった 立派なお寺ができて
ギリシア風の本堂ができたとかね
日本人の宗教だけど本山の建物の設計は
ギリシア神話風というのがあるんだからね
見てみてください 場所は控えます
もう一つの夢で
お釈迦様の膝までウジ虫がいっぱいついて
これも夢なんです
このウジ虫 なおさら気持ち悪くて
頭が黒くて体が白くて
もう膝までギュウギュウとウジ虫がついていて
この夢で結構気持ち悪くなったでしょう
それでその夢の解説は
釈尊が悟ってから説法すると
大勢の人々が仏教を聞くことになるんだと
仏教を信じて実践する人々になるんだと
その在家の人々がウジ虫なんです
だから信者さん獲得してよかったよかったと
威張ると思いますかね
その裏で何が読めるのかという
いかに仏教は人を管理しようとしない
ということなんです
マインドコントロールしようとしないことなんです
ブッダの威力にやられて
もうどうしようもないということじゃないんです
もしお釈迦様に言われたら そんなこと
あなたの威力でね
私はもう何もわからなくなって
あなたの信者になったんだよと
お釈迦様から ウジ虫だよとあんたは
いう話なんです
だからたくさんのエピソードあるんです
お釈迦様は私に超能力を教えてくれるならば
真面目に修行するんだぞと
お釈迦様「あんたに出家しろと私は言ったの？」と
すぐ反論するんです
キミ出家しなさい
私は超能力を育てる方法を教えてあげるぞと
私はそういうふうに商売したんですか？と
何といいますか あなたに勧めたんですか？と
いいえ お釈迦様は出家しなさいと勧めてないんだよと
だったら何言うの？あんたはと
それでこの前質問を受けたんですね
どなたか私が何か言ったポイント（について）
ということは 出家することではないかと言った途端
私の頭に別のアイデアが浮かんだんです
45年間説法をなされたお釈迦様は
一回も人に出家しなさいと言ってないんです
一回も 言ってないんです
すごいでしょう？
しかしどれほどの人が出家したのかと
それでも一回だけ お釈迦様は自分の息子
もう初めて会って 息子も父親に初めて会って
（息子は）7歳ぐらいなんですね
息子は父親にべったし もう体をつけて一緒に行くと
ラーフラ（羅睺羅） 子どもが「父親のものは私のものでしょう」と
だから私に財産をくれと
そしたら（釈尊が）サーリプッタ尊者に
この子は私の財産を欲しがっているんだと
私の財産（法・真理）がこの子にも入るように何とかしてあげてください
と言って出家させられたんです
当然それから 小さい頃は普通だけど
年頃になってくるとちゃんと瞑想も教えてあげて
瞑想して悟りに達しましたけど
悟りに達する時は大人になってましたけど
それでお釈迦様の財産（法・真理）が自分のものになったんです
そのケースだけですね お釈迦様は
人に聞かないで人を出家させたのは
しかしそれは父親だからね
誰も文句言えないんですよ
父親が自分の子供にどんな学校に行かせたって
誰が文句言うんですかね
（文句を言う）権利ないでしょ
それでもお釈迦様は批判を受ける羽目になったんです
自分の父親（浄飯王）から怒られたんです
あなたは父親の気持ちわからないのかと
あなたが出家してから
私はどれほど悲しかったか知らないのかと
私が育てた孫まで出家させたりして まだまだ子供でしょうにと
これからあなたはね
こういう親に悲しい思いをさせないでくださいと
すると お釈迦様も
やっぱりいくらお釈迦様であっても
父親の話は聞く
わかりましたと
それで禁止したんですね
親の許可なしに（子供の）出家は禁止だと
しかしお釈迦様は一人にも
「あなた出家しなさい」と言ってないんです
それでお釈迦様は真理を教えてあげて
どのように解脱に達するのかと教えてあげたところで
相手がこれ（出家）をやろうとしなければ
真面目にやるならば出家でもしなきゃ無理だなとか
本人が思うんであって
だからすごく気をつけていますよ
マインドコントロールにならないようにと
今話した伝承から 私たちがお願いしなくちゃいけないんです
何々してくださいと
お願いしますと 入れてくださいと
入れてくださいとこちらが頼んだならば
向こうの規則を守らなくちゃいけない
向こうはこういう決まりを守るならばOKだよと
だから一旦出家たら わがままは通じない
私はこれが好き これはやりたくないと言うと
まあ出て行けと
関係ないんだと
ということになるんです
しかし 出家した人々は一人も
マインドコントロールされているんだという気持ちは微塵もない
神父さんみたいにすごく怯えたり恐怖を感じたり
自己嫌悪に陥ったり まるっきりない
いつでも自分の意思で自分の気持ちで
自分がやりたいからやっているんだということなんです
そう言ったのは お釈迦様さえ
人をマインドコントロールしてないんです
なのにこの世の中はどうでしょうかね
自分を褒め称えて欲しくて
一生懸命我々のこの先天的な集中力
という弱みを握っているんです